[Musik]
der massenausbruch des corona virus bei
dem fleisch herstellern wiesenhof und
tanya verunsichert viele menschen dazu
haben uns die social media stars heiko
strohmann lochmann sowie anna maria und
katharina dann folgen das gesagt der
fenster an sich sehr wichtig und sehr
gut wenn man sich bewusst sein ich habe
für das was man isst ja da geht es ja
nicht nur um die gesundheit und was
vielleicht übermäßiger vielleicht konsum
auch mit der gesundheit macht sondern
auch der gedanke unter welchen
bedingungen fleisch produziert wie
diesen tieren geht und vielleicht die
mitarbeiter dahinter und wenn bei diesem
fleisch betrieb in die missstände waren
und die gab es ja offensichtlich dann
find ich super dass darauf auf messe
gemacht wird und das ist dementsprechend
eine reaktion gibt von der politik vor
den leuten das ist nur richtig und ja
dass ich glaube alles ist gesagt
gemessen wie das ja und das ist es dann
in uns drinnen in den menschen ja es ist
je weniger fleisch als vorher weil ja
keine ahnung gerade durch solche media
da saugt man die ganzen informationen
auf und irgendwann denkt man schon um
also bei uns war das zumindest so dass
wir dann gesagt haben also werden auf
jeden fall viel darüber denken woher wir
unser fleisch regen und wie viel wir
davon konsumieren also da haben wir auf
jeden fall deutlich reduzieren also es
hat irgendwas nehmen wir auch die augen
geöffnet
[Musik]